protogen named the protomolecule
and decided it was a tool that could
redefine what it meant to be human
jules pierre mao had treated it like a
weapon it killed humans
therefore it was a weapon but radiation
killed humans and a medical x-ray
machine wasn't intended as a weapon
holden was starting to feel like they
were all monkeys playing with the
microwave
push a button a light comes on inside so
it's a light
push a different button and stick your
hand inside it burns you
so it's a weapon learn to open and close
the door
it's a place to hide things never
grasping what it actually
did and maybe not even having the
framework necessary to figure it out
no monkey ever reheated a frozen burrito
hey guys pete here in the world of the
expanse the proto-molecule is the thing
that changed everything
holden's thoughts from abaddon's gate
there do a pretty good job of
summarizing what i talked about in the
first video of the series
humanity is the monkeys poking the shiny
box
making guesses about what it does while
everyone was fighting to control it the
proto-molecule was busy working
and in this video we're going to look at
what it built i'm going to explain what
we know about the ring gate
about the ring network it's connected to
the station at the middle of the hub
and what we learned about its builders
as we explore this
area as a warning this will contain
spoilers through season four
i'll also be referring to the source
material without giving future book
spoilers away the details are slightly
different between the books and the tv
shows
to save time i won't be pointing out
those differences i'm going to tend
towards what comes from the books but
overall we end up in the same place no
matter how you get there
with all that out of the way let's get
into it so as the monkeys were poking
things with sticks
the proto molecule was busy building it
hijacked aerostation
hurled itself towards earth got rerouted
to venus where it crashed on the surface
the work continued there until one day
it emerged as a giant mechanical squid
looking thing
that flew itself out past uranus and
assembled this giant gate
we refer to this gate as soulgate since
it connects our system to the ring
network
the ring itself is about a thousand
kilometers across
we're not exactly sure what it's made of
but the proto-molecule's influence and
its construction seems to make it pretty
durable
considering that some of this stuff has
lasted for billions of years
the gate is a wormhole and passing
through it is somewhat like passing
through a doorway
you're in one room you pass through and
you wind up in a different room the
wormhole connection here is that these
two rooms aren't next to each other
so passing through appears to be
instantaneous but in the act of doing so
you travel a great distance
so that's all pretty straightforward of
course we don't understand how the
builders mastered wormhole technology
or how they created the proto molecule
that can basically be programmed to go
out somewhere and build something like
this
but what the gate is and what happens
when you go through it that should be
pretty easy to follow
and when we look at the network it's
connected to their motivation seemed
fairly obvious
the builders were an advanced
civilization who were able to create
wormholes
it only makes sense that they would want
to locate other habitable systems
relatively nearby considering the vast
size of space
so that they could go and explore find
new resources
get a better understanding of what's out
there you name it
in my first protomolecule video i
explained the delivery system
of how they created these different
gates that eventually formed the gate
network
a question i see come up a lot is what
does it look like from the other side
i would assume that it looks exactly the
same and i'm guessing that that means
you could enter it from either direction
that said we never get a description of
this or an answer to that question
but remember when you pass through it
you end up somewhere else you end up
inside this hub
where all the ring gates are connected
i've seen this referred to as a
non-space
but as mentioned it's really a mystery
still at this point where the hub is
located
where it resides or where it physically
exists is also a mystery
there's no stars inside this space and
there's nothing that you could see on
the outside that you could use to locate
where you are
we call this the slow zone because of
what happened there it measures roughly
1 million
kilometers across surrounded by the 1300
plus gates which are all wormholes that
lead to different systems
the ring station at the center of the
hub is one place we've actually been
holden travels there he's followed by
martian marines
and in that process we learn more about
the builders than at any other time in
the series
as far as specs the station is about
five kilometers in diameter
we're not sure what it's made out of it
has this blue
glowing color to it and it's made with
something that appears to be metallic
there's no one on it no one from the
ring builder civilization anyway
but it does have an active security
system we see it activate that on the
ships that pass through
the soul gate ring that's where it gets
its name the slow zone as it changed the
speed limit and we get an example of
what it does to the marines
after it recognizes them as threats this
all seems to be built
in when the martians first approach
holden asked miller if he can stop them
basically he says yeah i can but
whatever he would set in motion he
wouldn't be able to control it or have
it do it in a way that wouldn't kill
them
i think what's most interesting about
the station and this security
system is its actual age it's ancient we
can imagine that it's been there for at
least two billion years
and it's still operational as far as its
builders this manifestation of miller
that leads holden
provides us some details about them we
don't know what they look like we don't
know what their biology is like
their history we just know that at some
point they sent out a bunch of probes
that were loaded with proto-molecule
which connected all these systems
together what we learned from proto
miller is
more about their extinction and we know
by his connection through the proto
molecule
and the fact that he's investigating
he's able to find records here he's able
to use holden to get access
to the system that they have constructed
some sort of hive mind and at this point
in the story
they do seem to collect things collect
the consciousnesses
of the life forms that they hijack julie
mal is the greatest example of this
on eros the living miller was able to
find her
imprinted consciousness and interact
with it it's also clear by this ring
network that's left behind
and its ability to create this
consciousness that resembles miller to
interact with holden
that it's created things designed to
survive
even after the civilization is gone
after the ring network was developed
the builders were wiped out they were
made extinct by unknown aggressors
some other civilization that we know
nothing about what we do learn from
miller at the ring station is that they
used it as a weapon
to destroy some of the systems that it
was connected to
it did this by sending a beam of energy
through the ring
that caused the stars to explode and
essentially vaporize everything in its
system
they tried this repeatedly without any
success
and so they eventually tried to
quarantine they tried to deactivate the
rings
that's why when they're first discovered
in our story the system isn't turned on
the quarantine didn't work either though
and we don't know if it's because they
shut down the rings or if the unknown
aggressors did something beyond what
we've seen
but at some point the alien civilization
the ringgate builders
went extinct miller brought holden into
the ring station so that he could gain
access
and in the process of that holden
actually experiences all of this stuff
happening he sees it
in the show we saw this as a sort of
dream sequence and he describes it
in the book as feeling connected to the
universe but also to this
hive mind it says he felt the stars
within him the vast expanses of space
contained by him
thousands of voices millions billions
lifted in chorus and he was their song
as he's experiencing this he sees the
star go out
as more of the sun start to fail he
describes how insignificant it feels at
first but how he starts to feel
fear and after a hundred stars are taken
out at once he says
this what had been a song became a
shriek holden felt his body shifting
against
itself furious as a swarm of bees
trapped and dying
in despair the hundred suns were burned
away the station hurling destruction
through the gates as fast as the
darkness
appeared but the growing shadow could
not be stopped all through his flesh
stars were going out voices were falling
into silence
death rode the vacuum faster than light
and implacable
he continues he felt a decision like a
seed crystal giving form to the chaos
around it
solid hard resolute desperation mourning
and a million farewells one to the other
the word quarantine came to him
and with the logic of dreams it carried
an unsupportable weight of horror but
within it like the last voice in
pandora's box
the promise of reunion one day when the
solution was found
everything that had been lost would be
regained the gates reopened
the vast mind restored after that he
wakes up
and miller seems to have absorbed all
this and he does explain some of it to
holden
for one thing he explains that for as
remarkable as miller
seems he's nothing compared to the
beings that created him
since these defenses are built in he can
turn the network back on but he isn't
sure what's going to happen
if the unknown aggressors return it's
possible that this station will start
blowing up systems again
we learned that the hive mind has a
function but also that through that last
part of what holden experienced
it is designed to outlast the people
that created it and it certainly does
hint that there may be a way that that
consciousness could be brought back
in the end before miller can explain
what he learned he disappears
as holden is apprehended by the martians
what's curious about where we're at in
our story
is that here are these monkeys again
poking stuff with sticks
the rings are again open and there's no
way that they're not going to use them
so we'll talk a little bit about what
they find right after this
i need to tell you about the sponsor of
today's video skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for creative and curious people
explore new skills develop existing
interests and get lost in creativity
i've been taking the course mastering
cinematic compositions in video and film
by jordy vandeput
it's well put together and it's taught
me a lot about setting up shots
if you're uncertain about what's next
creative challenges and productivity
classes can be a great way to help you
structure your time
and set up achievable goals at a time
when so many important conversations are
happening in our world
your voice is more essential than ever
explore classes to unlock your
creativity for social good
skillshare offers membership with
meaning connect with the support of
fellow creatives
and enter a community of encouragement
communication
and inspiration whether you're looking
to fend off boredom
focus on self-care through creativity or
join a similarly creative community
skillshare is the place to keep you
learning the first 1000 people to use
the link in my description will get a
free trial of skillshare premium
membership
and after that it's only around ten
dollars a month so check it out i think
you'll like it
in season four we did see that in
desperation
refugees on the barbapa cola ran the
blockade
and transited through the illest ring
and were able to make it to the surface
of this planet illus
they found that it was resource rich
there was a lot of lithium there
that's valuable and it wasn't difficult
to extract
and if they turned out to be successful
then there would be a lot of people who
wanted to follow their lead
and get out to these 1300 other systems
beyond its resources the other thing
illust had were large
artifacts large towers that were created
using proto-molecule by the ring builder
civilization
from what they can tell illust was once
used to generate energy
for the bigger project connected to the
alien civilization
and there was a lot of structures left
behind it appears that they used
proto-molecule to do some terraforming
this would appear to go beyond the
initial phase of development when they
sent a probe to this system and that
built the ring this appears to be
something that came
after that to better utilize that for
their civilization
and since the rasanante brought active
proto-molecule with them
that provided access for proto-miller to
poke around in the system
and turn things back on in the process
of that
they discovered an artifact which seems
to be left behind by the unknown
aggressors
they call it a bullet it's essentially a
round void
where proto-molecule can't go when this
system starts to defend itself from the
people that are on the planet
proto-miller is able to pass through
this and everything gets shut down
before he does that he tells holden
about the proto-molecule that's on the
rossi
tells him to destroy that which he does
and that severs their connection
and i think that's the right place to
bring this video to an end
next time i'll talk about the bullet
what we know about that
i'll get more into the investigator and
how he works and what we know about that
from the books
the ring gates really do change
everything again there are good reasons
why people want to go out
and colonize these systems but there's a
whole lot going on in the background
that they truly don't understand
holden has seen a vision of what
happened to the last civilization
that was using these rings to move
across the milky way and now they're
gone
miller was in search of a solution not
only of what happened but how to fix
things
and obviously he didn't come across that
before the connection was cut
it's wild when you think about it the
station's been sitting there for
something like 2 billion years
just waiting for something to come
through one of those rings
now humanity has done that and they're
rushing through
other ones to try to make a stake for
themselves
we can't say what it is but something's
bound to happen right so i hope you
enjoyed this video
please give it a like if you did please
leave any questions you have in the
comments
make sure you subscribe i'll be doing
more expanse videos throughout the rest
of its run
at some point i will revisit this series
with another part and i would appreciate
the support
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon